we have Sean cross who's going to be
talking about visualizing data analysis
pipelines with Panda's tutor and tidy
data tutor good afternoon
everyone so this is a real organic
screenshot of uh my desktop by day and a
similar screenshot by
night um you could easily say that code
dominates my work life um and I believe
that code is still important I think
that's part of the reason why we're here
at PA and conf and you know we're not at
Tableau conf or not at low code no code
com um you know those things are
certainly important and you know no
negative judgment on my part but uh I
think that there's still a really
important thing about building lasting
digital infrastructure with
code but there are some issues with code
that we just can't get around right uh
code can be intimidating you uh hear
about you're inheriting a new codebase
and you're like oh my gosh I can't
believe I have to get into this you get
into that that code and it can be opaque
you can read the code several times and
you don't even really understand what's
going on inside the code itself and it
can be overwhelming you get like a ton
of code files that you need to integrate
into a process that you're in charge of
um and it's just a lot to handle and to
me this kinds of sounds you know these
ideas of what's of what's what can be
wrong with code you know it sounds like
data in in a lot of circumstances
right what you know was different with
this audience though is that you know
most of us have a data science
background we've got all this knowledge
about tools that you know we can use to
dig into data and to kind of overcome uh
some of those challenges that I
discussed that you know that that data
and code
share so a question that I really want
uh you to ask yourself is what if what
could you build if you could apply your
favorite data tools to your code
um this is John McCarthy uh he invented
a lot of the fundamentals of computer
science including the programming
language lisp and he also had this great
idea that unfortunately I think has kind
of been forgotten which is this idea of
code as data or or code is data and what
I mean by this you know this phrase code
is data really refers to the idea that
source code written in a programming
language can be manipulated as data and
I don't know about you but that sounds
really exciting to me right because like
we've got all these incredible data uh
transformation and manipulation tools
that we're all very familiar with we've
been learning about them you know for
the last uh day at least you know
including the yesterday and this weekend
um wouldn't it be great if we could
apply some of these tools to
code and you know in R especially this
is kind of going on in the background in
ways that we're not even aware of so
take for example the single line of code
plot 1 to 10 right makes it very very
simple plot but how does r know that the
way that we're specifying the integers
from 1 to 10 is with this expression one
colon 10 right there are lots of
different ways you could write that in R
yet R knows that that's what we wrote in
the code and then it actually puts it
into uh into you know the y- axis label
here on this graph which is kind of
funny um so the the two things I want to
discuss for the rest of this talk is I I
want to show an example of what can be
built with this idea
of code is data um and then I want to
point you all in some directions of how
you can build with this concept of code
is
data so I work uh in the data science
lab at the Fred Hutch Cancer Center in
Seattle Washington and I am extremely
privileged because I get to work with
these incredible uh biomedical data
science practitioners um and these
incredible healthc care providers and
what a lot of them do is that they spend
half of their time uh in the lab at the
bench or they spend half their time the
clinic and they spend the other half of
their time kind of doing this right
they're looking at their computer and
they're you know they're they're looking
at at data they're transforming data and
a lot of you know the main data artifact
that they're dealing with all the time
is with data frames data tables that
we're familiar with and the way that
they choose to uh manipulate those data
frames is is through writing code
there's a lot of R written at Fred Hutch
and a lot of python written at Fred
Hutch um and you know these are just
kinds of the tools of the trade in
biomedical data
science and an artifact within this code
that you know I'm sure many of us are
familiar with is uh the data analysis
pipeline so I want to break down one of
these data analysis pipelines uh uh a
little bit the first Speaker mentioned
Penguins I'm going to talk about
penguins now um so the uh the the number
one is pointing to uh this variable
penguin penguins which represents and
contains a data frame about measurements
of Penguins taken during a scientific
study number two is uh a pipe a pipe
operator and what the pipe operator does
is that it takes the uh first it takes
the it takes what's on the left hand
side of the pipe operator and this case
the data frame penguins and it makes it
the first argument to the uh to the
function on the right hand side of the
pipe operator which in this case is
Select so what's happening here is that
the select function is picking out these
two individual columns from the
Penguin's data set uh the species of the
Penguin and the bill length in
millimeters the of of the Penguins um
and what's nice about this kind of data
analysis pipeline framework is that as
long as the function on the right hand
side produces a data frame you can Shain
together these functions and it's kind
of like a stepbystep recipe of the data
manipulations that are happening uh to
this data set right we're going to
select these two columns we're going to
group the rows by the species of the
penguin we're going to arrange the rows
in descending order according to Bill
length within each individual group and
then we're going to select the top row
in each group is essentially what these
five lines of code
say and I'm explaining these data
analysis pipelines to people relatively
often either people who you know I'm
onboarding them to some data analysis
code because they're going to be
changing it or they want to adapt it for
their own purposes or I also do some
teaching you know in different contexts
at Fred Hutch um and so you know if I
want to explain for example this filter
function I might draw a diagram like
this and say like okay on the left hand
side uh of the pipe this is the status
of the data frame then you know we're
going to cross all of these rows out
because they're going to get filtered
out and then the rows that are remaining
move up to the top of the data frame and
the same kind of situation with this
summarized example on the right hand
side so after draw drawing enough of
these diagrams you know I was I thought
well maybe I could kind of automate this
process a little bit so uh I I along
with uh colleagues of mine Sam Lao and
Philip guo built uh tidy dat tutor.com
and also similarly pandas tutor.com
which automates the creation of these
diagrams so for example if we start with
the code that I was discussing
before um the first thing that would
that would get uh illustrated by tidy
data tutor is the select operation so as
you can see we're picking out these two
individual columns the arrows show that
The Columns move from you know really
what's going on on the left hand side of
the pipe to the right hand side of the
pipe then we're going to group by the
species and so this the species is
highlighted on the left hand side and
then the you know Accord the group that
each row is in according to the species
gets uh an individual color according to
the group on the right hand
side um then you know we are we're
arranging within each group according to
according to descending order so you
know the rows get rearranged and you
know the Arrow show where each
individual row moves in that Arrangement
operation and then finally we're taking
uh the the top row off of uh each group
of the data frame right and just
returning the uh maximum build length
for each species in the final data
frame so you know this uh project has
been pretty popular so far um like I
mentioned there's also pandas tutor.com
and a lot of these ideas from tidy data
tutor and from Panda's tutor were uh
inspired by um our colleague Philip go
who buil python tor.com
um so you know those those projects are
just kind of like one example of of what
can be built with this idea of code as
data um I now want to talk just a little
bit and kind of point you all in in the
direction of you know how maybe you
could start building things with this
idea and I really hope uh that this will
facilitate a conversation and that we
can talk you know after uh after this
session um the first thing I want to
mention is uh a paper which actually has
a describes how a couple packages work
together that were built built by uh
myself uh Lucy mgan um and Jeff
leak uh that paper's called tools for
analyzing Rod the Tidy
way uh secondly I really encourage
everyone to read uh the uh
metaprogramming sections it's a couple
chapters of advanced R which is uh
available online for
free um and the other thing is you know
to that I encourage everyone to do in
terms of like an entree into what
packages can help you treat your code as
data is to mess around um with the rlang
package package it's a great package to
explore and and when I really got into
it it really changed how I see uh both
the code that I WR write and other R
code that I have to approach through my
work yeah so that's really it um I
really appreciate your attention and
thank you so
[Applause]
much thanks
Sean no questions in slider right now
but are there any questions from the
audience that you immediately had yeah
go uh go ahead and or actually you know
what I'll run this to
you uh hello so you introduced this as a
useful tool for new people who might be
taking over the codebase has this been
helpful in explaining what you do to
nonata
people that's a great question um so the
answer is is absolutely yes um it has
I've used it before in meetings uh both
with you know people who have a coding
background and people who don't really
to just like explain how certain
decisions were made during a data
analysis and also to kind of give them
another artifact both to like verify
that the logic that I'm using during a
data analysis process is is is like a
logic that they agree with um and also
is like an artifact that helps them
really have something to point to and
has and gives us like something much
deeper to discuss in terms of really the
decisions that are made in terms of you
know as we're kind of doing an ongoing
iterative data analysis
together any other
questions um
so what what I usually see um when when
these things are being explained like
the pipe operator that's been used on
multiple process that are used on top of
each other and um usually these things
are being explained with with tables
just like to explain how a left joint or
a right joint or an inner join or
something works and I think perhaps it
even uh works better to uh explain that
to nonata people when this is being used
in in real visualizations um when you
aggregate certain things or when you do
these uh uh pipe operators on the
several steps that are involved in the
the the the full stack of th those five
manipulations that you did on the raw
data of the I think the Penguins data
set or something um when when a real
scatter plot or something is being used
on just the raw data and then the
grouping and then the the filtering and
uh the aggregation because then you can
really see from a non data pers
perspective person that um you see what
the um what the unit of analysis is in
your in your data later on when you do
the aggregation versus what what is the
um unit of observation so what the
really uh raw data would look like I
think that would be a yeah perhaps a a
nice addition to uh yeah explain to non
dat people what these steps would really
mean because sometimes I really have the
idea that uh yeah these non dat people
think oh the only thing that they do
these people is is visualize the data
but you do so much more than and the
data visualization is usually just the
last step in that uh stacking of
pre-processing data before you you can
actually make sense of the
data yeah this the transformation of raw
data into anything else is
something spent a lot of time thinking
about and in fact one of the one of my
major Inspirations for that thinking is
in this room right now but
um I I you know illustrating that value
for different
stakeholders um would I think would be
really interesting you know the
challenges as someone else at this
conference said uh you know
all it's a it's it's a uh uh an anakaren
type of problem where all uh untiy data
is is different and all tidy data is the
same you know you know and so there's
it's hard to uh you know what's what's
nice
about what's what's nice about kind of
doing this reasoning about code is that
you know the logic in the code gives
things like a bounded structure where
sometimes like if the data is you know
if the raw data is messy enough like
they're the structure might be
incoherent I mean you know I've I'm sure
we've all been been you know down in
that dark place before but I appreciate
it thank
you